مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم الى هذه الحلقه
الخاصه من ما وراء الخبر والتي نقدمها من
العاصمه نسيت لاستجلاء ابعاد فوز السيسي
بالرئاسه
اذا فاز رئيس حزب نداء تونس بالانتخابات
الرئاسيه باكثر من خمسه وخمسين في المائه
امام منافسه الرئيس الانتقالي محمد المنصف
المرزوقي
واستنادا للهيئه العليا للانتخابات بلغت
نسبه المشاركه في جوله الاعاده ستين في
المائه ويواجه الرئيس الجديد وهو السياسي
مخضرم يواجه تحديات كثيره سياسيه
واقتصاديه واجتماعيه
وتعد التجربه التونسيه هي الانجح حتى الان
في دول الربيع العربي التي ثارت ضد
الانظمه القديمه
تصرح الهيئه بفوز المترشح السيد محمد
البيشي للانتخابات الرئاسيه
اختارت تونس الباجي قائد السبسي رئيسا
للجمهوريه سيخلف في قصر قرطاج منافسه
الرئيس المؤقته والمنتهيه ولايته محمد
المنصف المرزوقي رئيس حزب النداء تونس
يقود البلاد التي اطاحت بنظام زين
العابدين بن علي قبل نحو الاربع السنوات
الست الذي يشرف على التسعين عاما هو سياسي
مخضرم عمل تحت حكم الرئيسين تركيب او بن
علي فهل ستكون نتائج صناديق الاقتراع
كافيه لمنحه الشرعيه الكامله لدى كل
تونسيين باستثناء يبدو ذلك صعبا بعض الشيء
بالنظر الى ما سبق الاعلان الرسمي عن
النتائج النهائيه الاقتراع الاحد فقد شهدت
مدينه الحله جنوب البلاد مظاهرات معاديه
للرئيس الجديد حدث ذلك بعد اعلان حملته
الانتخابيه فوزه مساء الاحد بالرغم من ذلك
تبقى الاستثناء الوحيد في دول الربيع
العربي فقد نجحت في كتابه دستور توافقي
جديد وانتخبت برلمان يجمع اطرافا كان من
المستحيل ان تجتمع تحت سقف واحد
السابق خصوم حزب نداء تونس يرون في السبت
والحزب عوده لا سلام او لنظام بن علي و
انصار الحزب يحكمون بالفشل على تجربه حزب
النهضه في السلطه خلال الفتره الانتقاليه
التحديات التي تواجه الرئيس الجديد كبيره
وصعبه بدون عمليه سياسيه تشارك فيها جميع
الاطراف لم يتحقق شيء توجه الارهاب في
الشان في مناطق اخرى وتعاني من ازمه
اقتصاديه تفاقمت خلال الفتره الانتقاليه
شبح المظاهرات والمظاهرات المضاده وارد
الوقت الان الاحتفالات الفائز بالانتخابات
الرئاسيه ولكن بعد ان تنتهي نشوه الانتصار
سيبدا الاصعب في المرحله الجديده مرحله من
المبكر الجزم فيها الى اي مدى نجحت
الديمقراطيه في تونس ديمقراطيه استطاعت
على الاقل ان تتجنب حكم العسكر و سلاح
الميليشيات المتقاتله كما هو الحال في
الدول التي تاثرت يوما في تونس
وينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو في تونس
لمناقشه نتيجه الانتخابات ينضم الينا
القيادي في حركه نداء تونس الدكتور توفيق
بوش به وايضا اه الاستاذ عبد السلام
القتلى الباحث في الشؤون السياسيه
والاستاذ مراد يعقوب الاكاديمي التونسي
للمرزوقي نرحب بكم جميعا في هذا الاستوديو
بتونس
ونبدا لن تحدث طبعا عن اه دلاله هذه
النتائج اه استاذ يعقوب يعني تونس
والتونسيون انتهوا الان من المؤقت دخلوا
في الدائم اه برلمان حكومه والان الرئاسه
دائمه هذه النتائج انت كيف تقراها ما
دلاله فوز الباجي السبسي
الجمهوريه اه في واقع الامر هذه النتيجه
لم تكن مستبعده بالمره واعتبر ان اه
بدايتها او اشاراتها بدات منذ فتره طويله
نسبيا مع عوده اه نسبه مهمه من
الحرس القديم ان صح التعبير اه الى جانب
قوى اخرى من افاق متنوعه اجتمعت في حزبه
استطاع ان اه يلم هذا الشتات ويكون منه
قوه سياسيه اه فاعله والجميع وكل حتى
عمليه سبر الاراء كانت تسير في هذا
الاتجاه وتؤكد ان اه هذه القوه يمكنها ان
تحصد مزيدا من الاصوات من البرلمانيين وما
الى ذلك وهو ما حدث بالفعل وخلافا لما يقع
تداوله كل الاحزاب تقريبا كانت تنتظر هذه
النتيجه بما فيها الاحزاب التي كانت تنافس
على اماكن في ال في ال في المشهد السياسي
وبالتالي الصعود لم يكن اه بالنسبه الى ما
يمكن ان نسميه المجتمع السياسي لم يكن
مفاجئا ولكن الاشكال اخشى ان يكون كل هذا
المشهد المكون سواء من انصار السيد منصف
المرزوقي او انصار الحزب المنتصر او غيره
من المثقفين والفاعليه السياسيين اه على
هامش قوى اخرى تحتيه لا ترى في هذا الوضع
الجديد والذي اه لم تكن الانتخابات الا اه
يعني كشف اه له اه انه موجود وثبت وهو ان
اهداف الثوره الكبرى او حقيقه التغيير في
تونس لم يتم ولم يتم انجاز شيء فعلي وهذا
طبعا اه يجعل عدد مهم من ال من التونسيين
اه يحسون بنوع من الغبن السياسي الى جانب
هذا القرن السياسي هل هو في محله
اه دكتور توفيق
ابدا اه ما تم في هذه الايام وهذه
الانتخابات الرئاسيه وافضت الى فوز ولا في
مرحله التشريعيه حركه تونس وهذا يعني ان
الشعب منحها ثقته على نطاق واسع وجعل منها
الحزب الاول وهذا الحزب والان في البرلمان
الحزب الاول اه كذلك اه
الشعب يعني كان في معظمه اه
ملتف حول مشروع الاستاذ الباجي قايد
السبسي رئيس حركه اذا تونس والدليل على ان
اه ليس هناك اي
كما يقول البعض هو ان وان ال الحزب الذي
اسسه السيد الموسوي
سقط سقوطا
الانتخاب الديمقراطيه اه اه استاذ كليه
عندما يقول الاستاذ توفيق العاشره انه
الشعب كله التف حول برنامج وكل الشعب
الشعب التفاح هذا ما قلت التف حول برنامج
اه الباجي قايد السبسي لكن لاحظنا ان هناك
اختلافات جوهريه كانت واضحه في عمليه فرز
الاصوات في هذه الانتخابات هي ابعاد هذا
البلد الجغرافي عندما الجنوب يصوت لرئيس
المرشحان
والشمال والوسط يصوت
اه هل ترى لذلك ان تقرا في ذلك انقساما
جغرافيا يمكن للرئيس ال الفائز ان يتجاوزه
اه
بعد الانتخابات التشريعيه
تقريبا قسمت البلاد الى تقريب القسمين
الجنوب من الجهه والشمال من جهه اخرى
وحسب ال الارقام الموجوده لدينا والتي
كرستها انتخابات اليوم انت ميه ميه
لاهل الجنوب للمنطقه الجنوبيه
وللمنطقه ال ال ال داخل البلاد
على الاقل على الساحل هناك من
التصويت
واظن ان المساله لا تتعلق بالمرور يتعلق
بحسب ما اسباب حزب النهضه اه المحللون
يرون ان اه اهل الجنوب
ميلون الى نوع من المحافظه وان هذا الذي
يدعوهم الى انتخاب اه
احزاب الذات المولات هي نفسها محافظه على
ان هناك تحليل اخر سياسي مختلف جدا هو انه
لدى اهل الجنوب هناك رغبه حقيقيه في
التغيير ل انهم ربما يكونون هم الاكثر
عرضه ل ل هامشيه في تاريخ تونس باكمله
هناك رغبه حقيقيه لديها الجنوب في التغيير
وانهم لا يرون لقطع النظر اتفقنا مع هذا
الطرح او لم يتفق يرون ان هذا ال هؤلاء
الذين يحكموا لليوم لا يمثلون التغيير
افريقيا بل بالعكس يمثلون عوده للنظام
القديم وان كان باساليب جديده لاهل الجنوب
والمناطق الداخليه سواء اعتبرنا انه الت
التصويت جاء لاعتبارات عقديه عاطفيه
اخلاقيه او اعتبرناه لاسباب سياسيه عميقه
هذا كله في الحقيقه يحتاج الى شيء من
التريت لانه وقعه وهذا خطير واقع النفط
على ال على ال النعرات الجهويه
وهذه المعدات الجهويه اظن
للمختصين ان ينفذوا على هذه الارقام وان
يضعوا خريطه حقيقيه للانتخابات بحسب
الجهاد الاسباب العميقه التي دعت الجهه ان
تصوت لهذا او
طيب الدكتور سوف اعود اليك استاذ بعقوبه
اه بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع بالذات رغم انه
ال ال ال الرئيس الحالي اه المرشح الخاسر
اه المنصف المرزوقي اه يعني وجه كلمه ودعا
الى التهدئه هنا طبعا ال المرشح الفائز
ودعا الى التهدئه
وهذا اعتبر يعني اعتبر تقليد ديمقراطي
ولكن رغم ذلك شيء وحتى راشد الغنوشي وجه
كلمه الجنوب لكن رغم ذلك شاهدنا تحركات في
الجنوب
اه هي حركه الان الذين يشاركون في
انتخابات عليهم ان يقبلوا بينتج
الانتخابات هذه انتخابات ديمقراطيه وفعلا
يعني عشنا يعني انتخابات ربما فريده من
نوعها في المنطقه العربيه الى حد بعيد
مع اني لست مع الطرح الذي يقول ان هناك
انقسام في الجغرافيا
موجود يعني هناك من يطرحها هذا ال لست مع
هذا الطرح لماذا لان في ولايات مثل الجنوب
التي اه صوتت غير نقول بصوره اه م كفل
السيد الموسوي
لكن لم لا نجد ولايه مثلا فيها مائه في
المائه من الاصوات ايمن هناك نسبه معينه
للسيد الرئيس
ونسبه هي اكبر للسيد المرجوه بحيث ليس
هناك مائه في المائه اه من ال ال ال
ولايات الجنوب من صوتوا يعني لل سيد
المرسومي كما انها في الشمال هناك ايضا
كما يقول البعض ولايات عندنا اه فيها ايضا
اصواتهم
المستحيل
الجمهور في المشرق ربما يعتقدون من خلال
بعض الكتابات بعض الطروحات وبعدما بعض
القنوات التلفزيه
يعتقدون ان هناك انقسام هذا غير صحيح
لكن ربما اغلبيه
هذا هو قلت منذ البدايه نخشى ان تكون كل
هذه الخلافات يعني اه يعني سياق سواء كان
المرشح المرزوقي
وكل ال الطبقه السياسيه نخشى ان تكون فيه
وهناك عمق اخر يحرم الشارع السياسي يدعو
الى التهدئه
ان دعوه كل من الغنوشي والمرزوقي والبدء
الى التهدئه لم تعد الى التهدئه في الجنوب
ومنذ قليل سمعنا بحرق مقرات والتحركات ما
زالت متواصله
يبدو انها ستكون للاسف انا ستكون ليله
طويله حتى الليله في ال في السنه من
المؤسف اذن هناك
امور يعني عميقه في ال في المجتمع لدى قسم
كبير من الشعب التونسي ولا ولا انا لا
اتحدث باسم اي جزء يعني خلافا للاخ الذي
قال الشعب ملت ام هذه اللغه يعني لا
استعمله لاني لا اعتقد ان هناك من يمثل
الشعب التونسي الشعب التونسي يعني له
اختلافات ولهم اراء وهذا
عليه مسؤوليه قام بالمسؤوليه هل يستجيب
الشارع التونسي الشارع الذي انتظر اشياء
معينه قد لا يكون محقا فيها قد لا يكون حل
ما فيها قد يكون حل ما بذلك ولكنه اليوم
يحس انه السفاره من حلم ان الكابوس القديم
مازال متواصلا بقطع نظره حقيقه الوضع لان
الامر يمكن ان يكون مت وهما في داخله هذا
الوضع يؤدي طبيعه الى ان الناس لا تستجيب
وبالتالي لابد على الاحزاب وكل الاطراف
التي تحمل
انا من الجميع طيب
سنتحدث بعد الفاصل عن اه التجار التوجهات
التي اه ما هي توجهات التي يمكن ان يعترض
ها الرئيس المرشح الفائز ولكن بعد فاصل
قصير نناقش بعده هذه المسائل
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم الى برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الذي يبث مباشره من العاصمه
التونسيه تونس نرحب بضيوفنا مره اخرى
وابدا معك دكتور توفيق بوش به الان
بالنسبه للمرحله المقبله ندخل مرحله جديده
اه شكل التحالفات السياسيه الممكنه مع
الرئيس المنتخب الجديد هو ال اه لابد قبل
اجاب على هذا السؤال بصوره مباشره توضيح
ان نتوصل اليوم تعيش فرحه عارمه وال ال
الجماهير التونسيه كما نراها الان يستطيع
وجود بعض حالات الاضطرابات التي اعتقد
انها غربيه وستزول لكن بصوره عامه
التونسيون وتوصيات اليوم فرحه كبيره
ويشعرون بانهم رفعت عنه وان
وضع الان على السكه الصحيحه
والدوله ستوضع على السكه الصحيحه
برئاسه السيد الباجي قايد السبسي صاحب
الخبره والحقيقه وهو معروف عالميه نقول
والتهاني التي تلقاها اليوم من الرئيس
اوباما وبين الرئيس بوتفليقه وخاصه من
الرئيس بوتفليقه الذي تحدث عن شراكه تامه
وشامله وهذا سيكون في منطقه
بالمنطقه كلما
هذا
الان بالنسبه للحكم المقبل الان اه
الحكومه سيتم تشكيلها قريبا
والحكومه اه لا نعرف الان ربما السؤال ال
الاساسي الذي يساله البعض او يتساءل بشانه
البعض هل حركه النهضه ستكون ضمن الحكومه
هذا لا احد يعني يمكن ان يلزم به الان
سيتقرر عن طريق السيد الباجي قايد السبسي
هذه الايام اعتقد لكن هناك حساب اخرى
تشترك مع ان يريد اليد الى التوقع
حقائب وزاريه بالنسبه لحركه النهضه اه
حقيقه هذه نقطه استفهام حاليا ولا يمكن ان
نتوقع ذلك يعني اه حقيقه نقطه استفهام لكن
المؤكد ان حركه اذا تونس سيكون مع احزاب
اخرى من الاتحاد الوطني الحر السيد سليم
الرياحي الذي اثر بقوه الاستاذ
في هذه المرحله في الدوره الثانيه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه
ثم هناك حزب افاق تونس اه ربما ايضا جزء
على الاقل من الجبهه الشعبيه اه بعض
التنظيمات المستقله الاخرى
كفاءات بحيث ستكون حكومه اه اه فيها عدد
وافر من ال ال الكفاءات ومن السياسيين
اعتقد من احزاب مختلفه لكن الجوار هذه
الحكومه هوندا تونس سيد مراد ال اه يقوم ب
اه
المنصف المرزوقي الان سيكون ضمن خارج
اللعبه السياسيه النهضه القوى السياسيه
التي كانت في المعسكر ال
المنافقين السياسي هل ستكون قوه معارضه
برايك ان يتم اشراكها وتشترك في حكم
البلاد
المنصف المرزوقي هو شخص في نهايه الامر
ولكن نجح في جمع اه يعني طيف واسع من ال
من التونسيه كيف متنوع واحيانا متناقض
حوله وربما هذا الذي منحه تقدما مقارنه
بانطلاق صدر القرار الذي لم يكن يعطيه في
احسن حالات اكثر من بالمائه من ناحيه كتله
قويا موجوده على ارض الواقع ستكون في
الحكم في المعارضه من المستبعد ان لا
اعتقد ان ال اه ال يعني لا يمكن ان يشاركن
اه ولكن اه لماذا لانه عليه ضغوطات يعني
الاطراف اللغه وخطاب غزل بين الطرفين في
الايام الاخيره
الغزل الاشهر الاولى هو غزل الاستهلاك لا
اكثر ولا اقل ولكن او كل الانظمه تفعل هذا
كل المشاريع الحاكمه عندما تبدا تبدا ب
هذه ال بهذه الصيغه ولكن فيما بعد تتضح
الامور اكثر لانه على طول الفتره التي
تواجه فيها الطرفان سياسيه اقصى في
المواجهه كان هناك نوع من التناقض وحتى
عندما تكون مشكله بين النداء والمرزوقي
فان النهضه هي المستهدفه في الخطاب
الاداري هذا يراه ال ال الجميع وبالتالي
اه تشرك الناس يبدو اه امر صعب بين وان
كان يمكن يعني من الوارد ان الظرف الحالي
اه ببعض المظاهر ال التم ل ل ال الموجوده
والتي لا اظن انه يجب ان اه انه مصغره
منها ونعتبرها من مجرد امر ظرف يجب
الانتباه اليها لان هذه يمكن ان تشكل وضعا
يتجاوز الجميع ويسقط السقف على الجميع
وبالتالي لابد من الانتباه اليه اذن هذه
التحركات التململ الذي بدا بصوره اه بسيطه
ولكن يجب العمل حتى ل يتوسع يمكن ان تغير
المعادله وتدفع بالفعل الى تكوين
وسنه بسلام كل هؤلاء هل يمكن ان يشكلوا
جبهه معارضه ضد السلطه للدفاع عن اصبح
يسمى في تونس بيئه الدفاع عن المكتسبات ال
الدستوريه خاصه وان هناك بعض الاطراف
اصبحت تتخوف من تغول ال السلطه اه
حزب المؤتمر سلمت حقيقي في المجلس ولا حتى
في ال في القاعده الشعبيه ال المعارضه
الحقيقيه
تمارسها وهذا الذي وقع في الحقيقه
سنوات الذي سمير المعا في المجتمع الذي
بمعنى الاتحاد ال السعود وكل المجتمعات
الجمعيه الاهليه التي في تونس يتمثل اه
سيد مهم سيد نضال ي مهم
اريد ان اقول ان يرى انه حتى هذا المجتمع
المدني وذكرت اه الان الاتحاد التونسي
العام الشغل يقال انه منون بلون سياسي
ايضا ومصطفى تيار معين مهما يكون الامر لا
اظن ان هذا المجتمع الذي مارس النظام على
مدى اه السنين لا يمكن
على انه سيسمح بالاعتداء الحريات ومن
الحريه النقابيه والحريه العامه والخاصه
او الاتفاق على العداله الانتقاليه لا اظن
ان هذا سيحدث على انه في الداخل في داخل
المجلس اذا فرضنا انه ستكون خارج الحكم
وان كان هناك اشارات وانا استند الذي
اشارت له لا الى توقعات الى اشارات فقد
كانت سياسي اربع خمس ايام تصريحا واضحا
وقال ان النهب ليست خارج التفاوض على
الحكومه التفاوض على الحكومه على الدخول
ولكن انا اظن انها ست شهر و انا لا استبعد
ون الحقيقه لا استبعد ان يقع ادماج انها
ضمن هذه الحكومه والا فان الحكومه ال التي
ستاتي في الحقيقه ستكون في صعوبه لانها لن
يكون لها الاغلبيه الكافيه للحكم خاصه وان
الدكتور احيانا يشير في بعض اه اه ال ال
ال القوانين التحضير الدستور او هذا يشير
الى اغلبيه بالثلثين بمعنى ان تدخل
باغلبيه مائه وعشرين نائب اظن ان هذا ليس
مريح وسيجد ان يدار صعوبه كبيره في تاليف
هذه الحكومه خاصه وانه يعلم ان اليسار
التونسي الممثل في الجبهه الشعبيه ليس من
برا وانه قد لا يقبل الدخول في هذه
الحكومه اذا استثنينا النهضه استثنينا
الجبهه الشعبيه استثنينا كل المثل الصغيره
او ال العناصر الصغيره المؤلفه للاحزاب
فانني دكتور شو هذا ما يقوله الخبراء وهو
امر ملموسه محسوب بال بال اعداد سيكون في
وضعيه
وهذا الذي يجعل واعتقد انه سيفكر كثيرا
قبل ان يدخل اللحظه اولا يكون لها في
الحكومه
دكتور توفيق نتحدث قليلا عن السياسه
الخارجيه ايضا طالما اننا تحدثنا عن
الداخل واه يعني المتوقع ك تحالفات لكن
بعد ان تكتمل ال ال الصناعه اه لنقل البيت
السياسي اه امام اه الحكم الجديد ملفات
سياسيه تقيله على مستوى العلاقات الخارجيه
هناك عداء مع بعض الدول اه عندك سوريا
عندك مصر عندك الملف الليبي المشتعل وهو
على الحدود كيف يمكن ان يتعامل الرئيس
المنتخب مع هذه الملفات ودائما السياسه
الخارجيه الناجحه تكون انعكاس للسياسه
الداخليه التي تكون يكون ادائها جيد ومن
حيث السياسه الداخليه سننطلق من ارساء
وتعزيز دوله القانون وهذا هو مشروع دوله
القانون دوله العدل هذا المشروع ال
الاستاذ عيسى رئيس الجمهوريه العربيه
ثم السياسه الخارجيه هناك اصلاحات كثيره
يجب ادخالها عليها اولا ذكرتي موضوع سوريا
موضوع سوريا
المغامره ادخل اه سيد المرزوقي تونس فيها
دون اي موجب وهذه المغامره هي مغامره غير
محسوبه
نعيد العلاقات مع سوريا ان شاء الله
بالنسبه لمصر كان لان ال اه قطع العلاقات
مع سوريا كان ايضا رساله للتشجيع على
انتقال الشباب والانضمام الى التنظيمات
الارهابيه هناك في سوريا وهذا ثابت الان
كانت رساله رساله سيئه ويجب الرجوع يعني
الى هذا الموضوع
وايضا الخروج باستنتاجات
حول الملابسات ايضا التي حوله وستكون هناك
اعتقد سيكون هناك تحقيق نوع من الاتهامات
ستكون هناك على طبعا احنا هذا تفكيرنا
اثنين اه لانه احنا ضد قطع العلاقات مع
سوريا وهذا ضد المصلحه الوطنيه التونسيه
وقلناه وانا اكرر بالنسبه
بالنسبه لمصر اه سنسعى الى تعزيز العلاقات
بافضل ما يمكن مع مصر لان اه ايضا هنا
السيد المرجو لي اه كان قد مارس تدخلا في
الشان الداخلي المصري ولم نكن اراضينا
عليه من ليبيا بالنسبه ليبيا ليبيا اه
جاره اه بطبيعه الحال
المشاكل ايضا التي الامنيه وال اه التسليح
الارهابيين اه مصدره اساسا من ليبيا ولكن
نحن نريد ان تستقر الاوضاع في ليبيا
وسنعمل
الاطر الامميه وكذلك الاقليميه التي اه ت
اه
تحركها بصوره ايجابيه لحد الان وان في
حدود الجزائر اعتقد ان هناك مجموعه من
الدول سنكون ضمنها لمساعده الليبيين على
ايجاد حل سياسي وليس حل عسكري حل سياسي
بحيث نريد ان تستقر الاوضاع في ليبيا
وانذاك ستكون الامور جيده بالنسبه ليبيا
وتونس شكرا لضيوفنا شكرا للدكتور توفيق
باشا القيادي في حركه نداء تونس شكرا
للاستاذ عبد السلام الفكري الاكاديمي
والباحث في الشؤون السياسيه
وشكرا ايضا للاستاذ المراد اليعقوبي
الاكاديمي التونسي حدا عم بيمارس اوكي
شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا شكرا ل مشاهدينا على
متابعه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر والتي قدمناها لكم من العاصمه تونس
نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده في ما
وراء خبر جديد لكم منا منا القمه
ام